Yes you are you were there to live. You're
finished when diver alma. Yes. Yeah
that's how i i took notice
of what was going on and
condemn the bridge and now i've got four
million you know the weird part and i
walked up and asked him without
a job. Tell me do you did you hear anything
about the tunnel under the harbor that
they had to put the tramway cable
through did you finish in about
1923 i understand. No no no no
no i can men you know want. So
it was the 1927 when you got your we got
you got your license and that job in the
first place and then you the mail contracting
job when i was twenty eight. Was it
twenty eight. Was it when the mail
contracting job came up was it was it 1928.
Yeah yeah. And the end of every just
like the poor question. twenty eight.
Had been like into december twenty eight
when actually it started on the first of
the. And you carried on as mail
contractor right through until
nineteen eventually into
1950s was no i mean had
carried it on for about twelve
mansion but i told them no no no not
a job i was an out of work you
know and that's got i think
a date and time twenty nine.
But later on you had the
job as well. Contracted and you know
i got i got the job. It started in
twenty nine but i actually started the
day before the pilot broke down. And i
started. I just bought
a new buick. And that wyatt
mentioned card and tried
it which i did but it only it was just
report christmas twenty eight but the mail
contract to my shop never started and
the first of january had it work on
a perch again you buy it or no all
a days then and i continued
out on and bought
into them and i bought rob out then when
robertson brothers were run and they my
on the train they when
combined them high. I sold
my section or swapped a
portion of the contract to
a fellow due to run between here and
cabana and i bought bagan kabar the one
burmese and section and one. And i have
a floater of that day and. I
contend and then until a fellow beat
me right and passion. So i don't start
a con logon contract and pole contract
them myself and i've been on an oil for
the mail and log track and ever changing
my header ship me logs as read any until
the shipping servers run
out. You know and i have
a month voter of that my log depot
on the headland here to this
day and they give you the british
empire medal in the end all along usa
services. Yea. There's
a you know i wonder whether p m g
and i got records and. Thanks and
repetition appear materials i never asked
why they just sent along to me on my long
faithful service and you joined the
army during the war. What age were
you in the us with about thirty five point
thirty can't remember my age and i'm.
I don't think i'm
a birther no. And i haven't fought all those
times on to join the war when the war
venison to overseas know i got got as
far as new guinea. That's obviously
but we knew we never done
a fight and we were more or less where in
that then the battle when the when the
japs are on over. We were actually never
done sure baten we already see mosher to
know him. And then merchants rather
and we were and said the night
the emden not in the
raider sank the sydney
and you know that result in western australia
we didn't know where we were and in
pitch every degree black out and we partner
graydon. A week before what must have
been her at midnight. Now then crashed
in and she was the one that laid the the
mines and sent the name
on and union company passengers and
use them and i just can't think
of my name address. I don't see it and
know what show on that had all the gold on
which they mostly retrieve gritted which
he was sunk by head of mine when i was
telling and the radio
that sank the sydney.
Where is one i never got either
in
a row now only or flowed and you and i
remember that. Well we were three then and
i are eventually i got back to sydney and
i in wish we were up
everything and went on the
answer. A judge and for they
now and i was mostly in
and in the northern part of australia when
when the japs come into
it. I was in it for
a while but the point is i was
in the one darwin got bombed
and we you know not an outdoors and i
remain there they are never sure sheens
were spread all over the place we never
knew our war was to australia it and when
japs and then at
a jump then then i got i walked over the
place. There were you in the window. We
were outside when i try and. But
a lot of my followers are all around it.
There are more people level people killed
and didn't know existed where
you bombed at all. And what oh
yeah yeah you know rage but not
the big one the big one came
after which had regained our
lead up to it right down to.
So what did you do it at the right time
of the reeds do you clear up afterwards
a word. How do you mean what was
your job there. I was driving
a lieutenant say i was in the drive and
traction. I didn't know where obama next
day and i often think that you never know
where we're gonna be but they made you
mean one whale what nine grams
couldn't. But the golden and
major jolly was ahead of our unit. Call
on jackman row in the new world in the
timber drain and they used to call me
sassafras. Treasure threshers logs ways to
get out of norman dairymen
and it really funny
a to deal start of born bloody
line. I did to my fam some sort of
a tree. It wasn't drink you buggered. They
were down there but i got got over an
axe and strung it all up and got to go on.
I did. It was in the wet all and time i
was. We were stand no screaming like dogs.
I'll never forget it. It was funny side
of the makes me love one of think
of it and why that time. Then
he yanks were all there and i met
some mighty guy never struck
a crook on my good follows true. I don't.
So we had you get the names as
a for us. My lieutenant
lindstrom able to next
schoolteacher and he'd be in charge of
the unit. Some days remain as if anyone
knows the runnings of the
army. You always got out
a day or no way they were in front
line or the back line. What they call
a rest day and
a fundamental name about tamba that i used
to cut there on the dock at george mount
much trees for our tribe this door.
And he questioned me shattered and
leinster when he'd be in charge of the
unit and these day all he'd give me
a day wolf with him. So you could have
a mate and friend. And i wouldn't
take. I wouldn't take another as
a job at all and i was offered the
money call and in the song they'd call
him home. The store not
a global village just license and in charge
of the sturgeon area in the store. What
you call an quartermasters
called i would i was called
a martyr's store to take charge about in
the unit my time at now and i should come
out again. You know much quicker to
care and i'm not going to take on any
responsibility. But as times went on that
was it was still a melon. In
a sole cause as you know to put in the
young follow through it. And they always
take me out on the truck just to provide
followed it probably never seen an action
before they cut them and one place would
i remember and campbell singleton they
made good use for me with
my knowledge but i was
a never done work. And i
wouldn't take i wouldn't take
a higher position but there to call me
that it do that you've got to be what they
call
a bomber there and i just died. It
had and i never even standard what
you call it and you get to your manner.
You know you make it when you go in
our pay. How how much
money down there army
. Families are gonna name
for it didn't then make
everyone done it pretty well about the only
one i didn't have money blog like than
you know star much to my mother and your
keeper shown by your job. What is it. I
can't remember you can't or what
is on my mind madrid i would make
a big try to talk and tell them
you want me up like a blog. I did
a name for an allotment. Alright
allotment and i didn't i didn't know
there was only get in the minimum bob
a day and that wasn't enough to keep me
and there. And i never forget the day i
come right up to gidon and happen to
be another fellow that comes from down
a great friend of mine married
a girl and i wasn't very fond
of going to. And when they got
a judge judge in the showground that was
a general details job on the lawn sent back
from where we started problem and that
it should get his gi destroy him.
They are doing him and we had
a deferred pay and the pay book and
they are today are much money. We want
and then and when going to have
a day out together i've said
i have ten bounce i got £10
a remailer nearer four and we
live by my standard we have
a day and his name and he's
still here and in kampala.
And that's about all i can tell you you
never got married yourself now. And you
know you were keen on that girl on that
matter of fact i think i'll give it
a last ride in the car last time machine
and she lived. Bro go out again and
it was a. Yet chapur mention
a name which i was discharged when he
ended up marrying and i haven't seen
a change and i'm still single and i'm still
level alone. When you build us house.
Did you build it yourself. Yes where
but when i talk to male oh man i'm
220 a twenty nine. And we've had it has
a lot to none. And we're only cameron
n i back was and forward fishin where you
can tell we are venturing that i come
down this site to this day and built this
on it and i call and nurse called it
a day and a million dollar
a million dollar. You
know cite what economy in
a million dollars million million dollar
view because of the million dollar view
and a desert can't be built out just
say you can stand out there and have
a look yourself and that's our good name
a million dollars. And that's about all i
can tell you up that died when i went out
on the end of the timber trade
probably then and as well as
a mile and i fish it the longest of all as
brothers and certainly by ship and i had
my own depot down here which i have
a poet or in letters addition day and what
happened when the ship was unaware with
you. Shipping to my lighted nearby road did
you know i went out of that altogether
and back mail try and try again via
tartar. And then we had a big flood
a down there and. When i was to have
a punt of course it can't punt went this
way and i was cut off at that and i don't
go back over the mountain.
Whereas data not
a couple of days report questions of 1928
and here i am and make it here. Now i'm
still looking to and house where
i started from 1988. 1928 and
then in 1988 and that's all i can do and
that's true actually sixty one years
on the on that side at this moment and i've
handed my license and i've still got it
with the same address. Just because
they are just burma going on
a. And you. What do you get for that
for service to the community and
the be for the same person and
that's as mailman. Now all those years
and not only that my car acted. I used
to be an amorous here but
i know i am called out
a better trail clock and i more and take
them along to the maternity ward and bang
my own and in plane and
i remember one morning.
Go on an old coast road one pull up on
carrie gander bridge here in pain and it
was a just about five to seven while we
pulled up on around here with me and
a nurse taking
a wrap on the maternity ward of the old
beggar hospital and the convent balance
seven o'clock on the moon and. I never
forgot that but we've got out there as you
put the baby arrived and. I
and i was called out at night
and i am wondering why i was hacked and
the hammers man as well as contriving
do you remember dromedary in the old
days you member drama day where i got
a stash of bears out.
And even going to have
a look. I don't say that's what i call it
a million million dollars and what about
old central tool but did you. Well i tried
a lot to do what i wanted i was there
get my men out of the mountain. That i
wore finished. Get
a mountain and there was no bear talk i'm
down to the local pub at dromedary and
all ad where he snaps and
and all cordial. To drink.
No beer and i never got to follow the rich
nigga nothing. The temblor out for me.
He has just done a little
there's a little make there is
a full quote they said jack.
For old tom doyle he is just
data that better you mean me. I never
get so here i am and i mean they're
retired and. Looking out to me so natural.
I can tell you i thank you very much mr
. No i don't like mr other christian jack
and jack i'll remain. Thank you very much
for calling on our swimming at
a further go now. You live on my british
beach up and thank you thank you. And
tanner. You member some story was
a funny side of the army.
You know i just can't stand on it when i
get started on one but it makes me think
some are not and where was it you remember
holder somewhere up north queensland.
What was it related to driving or just
a funny engine and right dutch can't think
what is it about ireland over and i even
laugh at short i woke up a measly
bit more of a dream. It wasn't
a dream at all. It was true. Richard but
remonstrated what really happened. The
funny. The funny side of the army and then
yet one of the mates i add he got landed
in uganda and i didn't but it was on
a time bomb going to ground
and it blew his two legs.
A weirdo batman how captain town but i
never we never got i'm sure they're afraid
to bloody scare was one that would stop
marines and bomb hundred or not an
invasion full of law there but we're on the
ships you know. And next thing we about
to night should two days later patched
up where we ended up in darwin not
darwin towns well that's all i can
tell you about and i can't think what
a story but to mount it really yuma should
punish writers time and i can't think
what i've been so holier up to much.